[Musique]
c'est vraiment un petit paradis si le
vraiment vraiment
[Musique]
petit paradis nommé terrebonne diane et
lucien ont choisi de s'y installer à
temps plein il ya dix ans alors en tête
toujours en floride on y voit vue on est
venus ici et ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à s'établir à terrebonne pour
sa localisation près de montréal et
laval à proximité de deux autoroutes
notamment la ville grandit les projets
domiciliaires poussent un peu partout
mais terrebonne a aussi connu son lot de
perturbations
l'upac a frappé en 2016 cinq personnes
dont l'ex maire ont été arrêtés puis aux
dernières élections les citoyens ont
choisi marc andré plante on avait besoin
de faire le ménage de moderniser
l'administration municipale et
aujourd'hui on est en meilleure posture
terrebonne se transformer cette race
tonnes d'une belle façon il sollicite un
deuxième mandat sa promesse protéger le
portefeuille de ses citoyens
son principal adversaire mise plutôt sur
le changement ça prend une nouvelle
accroche donc au cours malheureusement
du dernier mandat eu beaucoup de
divisions beaucoup de confrontations
que conflit avec les employés municipaux
s'est invitée dans la campagne ces
derniers dénoncent un climat de travail
toxiques congés maladies à répétition
départ précipité à la retraite de
nombreuses plaintes en harcèlement il ya
aussi une démotivation qui est
généralisé à la ville de terrebonne la
cour est pleine
tous les grands syndicats de la ville
pompiers policiers col blanc col bleu
ont formé une alliance en 2019 certaines
conventions collectives sont échues
depuis trois ans oui on a des bonnes
conditions ce qu'on dénonce encore une
fois c'est vraiment le climat de travail
qui est toxique à la ville de terrebonne
la diminution des services aux employés
et nous on pense qu'on a besoin d'un
vent nouveau pour aller se rasseoir aux
tables de négociations mais il faut
s'assurer que la progression des coûts
de conventions collectives suivent la
progression des revenus de la ville et
aujourd'hui je peux malheureusement pas
pour les familles puis les retraités
dire on va piger à nouveau dans leur
portefeuille pour financer ces
conventions collectives il faut trouver
un équilibre
l'environnement aussi au coeur de la
campagne électorale
on veut de terrebonne plus faire ça
faire au niveau de la lutte aux
changements climatiques
on a vu que à l'échelle locale on était
capable d'avoir des changements qui ont
finalement une influence sur le global
et donc on veut apporter notre
contribution aussi dans cette lutte
environnementale
il est aussi beaucoup question
d'améliorer la mobilité durable puisque
la congestion est importante à l'heure
de pointe les gouvernements péquistes et
libéraux nous ont beaucoup délaissé sa
couronne en daim deux dernières
décennies on a eu beaucoup de promesses
et l'aujourd'hui il est temps d'investir
beaucoup de gens avec s'en viennent en
banlieue fait que la circulation devient
de plus en plus denses seront pas des
gros stacks ans ça fait que ce soit
l'hiver les déneigement l'été c'est pas
propre les rues ses propres pour moi
c'est l'environnement c'est des causes
principales lors que j'aurai beau petit
ceux déjà fait d'ailleurs
plus de 14 % des citoyens ont déjà voté
par anticipation faire bonne c'est
pratiquement deux fois plus qu'en 2010
est ici qui me permettra au canada à
terrebonne
[Musique]